de gigantesques canton recouvert lancé
en héliport du centre hospitalier de
cayenne
voici l'hôpital de campagne fraîchement
installée pour accueillir les patients
non atteints par le coronavirus et
malgré l'apparenté rusticité des lieux
un matériel médical ultra sophistiqué il
ya été installée pour traiter les futurs
patients
un dispositif d'urgence déployée car
l'hôpital de la ville ne dispose pour
l'heure que de 16 lits de réanimation
adapté pour le coc vie 19
selon la ministre d outre mer ce renfort
est indispensable alors que le nombre de
personnes infectées guide de chaque
semaine dans le territoire cet hôpital
il comporte 3 et bien c'est 20 lits de
médecine générale
ces avaleurs opératoire séance
cantonnement opérationnelle la
logistique sera géré par les équipes de
l' élément de sécurité civile rapide
d'intervention médicale l'escrim un
personnel à la fois civile et militaire
l'unité se concentrera notamment sur le
traitement de pathologies ne nécessitant
pas de loup prise en charge
nous assurons les patients dans leur vie
pour assurer l'animation dans provident
si les pathologies typique encore
examiner si les cartes classiques c'est
la situation épidémique en guyenne est
suivie avec préoccupation par le
gouvernement français la ministre d
outre mer a appelé les guyanais à
respecter plus strictement les gestes
barrière et le port du masque
de son côté la préfecture de guyane à
renforcer les mesures de restriction
pour lutter contre l'épidémie
fermeture des bars et restaurants sur
tout le territoire confinement ciblé
d'une vingtaine de nouveaux quartiers
fortement touchés et durcissement du
couvre-feu
la guyane devrait rester sous état
d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'à la fin
octobre
le pic de
l'épidémie est lui attendu pour la mi
juillet